estos anuncios que hacen parte de esta
orden ejecutiva de esta ayuda adicional
de 13 mil 600 millones de dólares que
eeuu le brindará al crearía
concretamente 800 millones de dólares
irán para entre otros para
específicamente para ayuda militar
incluye entonces estos 800 millones de
dólares
800 misiles tierra-aire para elevar
aviones esto en respuesta a la demanda
que hizo esta mañana el presidente
ucraniano borovinsky de cerrar los
cielos y que si eso no era posible
enviar más aviones el presidente de
bailén le responde a célestin diciendo
que pues estos misiles son bastante
efectivos esos misiles tierra-aire
precisamente para contrarrestar este
ataque aéreo de parte de los rusos
también incluye 9.000 misiles para
atacar tanques incluye 7 mil armas de
largo alcance y 20 millones de rondas de
munición para armas pequeñas medianas y
largas incluye también drones y aquí
también fue específico el presidente o
alguien en resaltar que hay también todo
una ayuda cibernética y tecnológica a
ucrania para contrarrestar el ataque y
la aviación rusa esto hace parte
entonces estos 800 millones de dólares
irán directamente ayuda a habilitar
hacen parte del largo paquete de 13 mil
600 millones de dólares que ya firmó hoy
así contados segundos desde la casa
blanca el presidente ve a bailén y de
estos 13 mil 600 millones de dólares
cerca de 6 mil 500 irán a defensa para
pues más despliegue de tropas más apoyo
militar y cerca de cuatro mil millones
de dólares irán directamente ayuda
humanitaria es decir también a la ayuda
de los refugiados de cerca de tres
millones de refugiados que ya tiene un
crédito cristóbal esta ha sido una
mañana de muchas noticias primero hablo
volodymyr excelente el congreso de los
eeuu y después respondió el presidente
ruso vladimir putin diciendo que se
cumplirán los objetivos en ucrania
cuáles son las reacciones desde
washington y por qué algunos critican a
los republicanos se ve que pidieron más
sanciones
en este discurso de volver y ser en
sequía ante el congreso discurso
televisado a nivel nacional que fue en
el vídeo pues se le mostró un vídeo
corto en el que mostraba la ucrania de
antes y de ahora después de los ataques
con niños muertos personas heridas y eso
hizo llorar e hizo pues bastante
emocional a muchos congresistas que
estuvieron en esta sala muchos de ellos
se emitieron comunicados tras este está
y está este vídeo que presentó el
crecimiento global se les quita y la
crítica que se le hace a los
republicanos es que ellos al mismo
tiempo están presionando al presidente
demócrata yo bailé el de que ponga más
sanciones de que sean más estrictos con
rusia y que pero al mismo tiempo están
criticando la inflación
acá en eeuu inflación derivada
precisamente de las sanciones al
petróleo y a la energía rusa es decir
están ganando por el lado apoyo cuando
están pidiendo más sanciones a la casa
blanca pero también ganando
pues la crítica a la inflación derivado
de estos costos energéticos cristo